[Music]
what's going on guys
Halloween right around the corner which
means it's time to break out the scary
movies and scary movie monsters I'm
talking your Dracula's your
Frankenstein's your Donald Trump's and
no scary movie monsters plato's on
stompin as the walking Undead themselves
that's right
zombies thousands of zombies have been
stabbed impaled headshotted over the
years but we took on the gargantuan task
narrowing down all of that to the top 10
zombie kills ever yeah number 10 on our
list comes from the first zombie movie
ever
what is it Night of the Living Dead you
asked that coming to get you Barbara
no it's 1932 s white zombie it is
acknowledged as the very first Hollywood
zombie film now the zombies in white
zombie are just as mindless as
modern-day zombies but a little easier
to kill just kind of guide them to a
cliff and get out of the way that's what
that works
[Music]
fun fact George Romero himself
considered these kinds of zombies not
the ones that he created to be the
actual zombies now lucky for us the
bitey Irwin's prevailed and we don't
have to watch dozens of movies about
slow-moving brainwashed people kind of
just ambling off buildings that would
have made Walking Dead a slower next on
our list are killed from today's
foremost showcase of zombie brutality
The Walking Dead this AMC show has
dispatched walkers in every way you
could imagine over the course of its run
but we chose one from the world's
dirtiest and most badass zombie hunter
Daryl Dixon
that zombies gotta be like pretty
embarrassed they got killed like that
the other zombies are probably like oh
did you hear about Pat he's got his head
crushed with a Subaru
coming in number eight it's another
entry from the world of television Game
of Thrones
ever since season one we've been
watching the glacially slow advance of
the army of ice zombies known as White
Walkers and before you give me that
whole they're not zombies speech um
they're Undead
difficult to kill skeleton people who
reanimate the dead they're zombies
deal with it anyway after years of being
practically unkillable boogeymen one of
the ice men got spectacularly deep sixed
by none other than the bastard Jon Snow
in season fives most badass episode
hardhome oh you know nothing Jon Snow no
you know one thing had a smoke a zombie
ice guy at number seven we got a kill
from a modern zombie comedy zombie land
Jesse Eisenberg and Woody Harrelson and
company racking up tons of kills as I
trekked across America but this one
takes the cake because it helps rid the
world of the only thing worse than a
horde of unstoppable Undead
you clowns coming in at number six the
director of Batman V Superman
illustrates what happens in the Battle
of shotgun V propane tank tell you what
happens to go boom
fYI the guy that shot the propane tank
also plays Doug Stamper on house of
cards
which keeps my hopes alive that the show
ends with zombie Frank Underwood lording
over a nation of undead Netflix make it
happen speaking of George Romero we
couldn't leave his og version of Dawn of
the Dead off the list his 1978 original
up to the Andy when it comes to zombie
gore best illustrated by this zombie
idiot who gets too close to a
functioning helicopter at number 5
[Music]
wait a second look at that guy's head
what's up with that head he's got like a
Mardi Gras head you know he must have
gotten teased on the playground because
of that a head
poor guy coming to zombies the best
thing that ever happened to him then he
gets cut off by a helicopter
oh nothing one right for this guy he was
born with a big old dumb head then he
gets turned to his Dom it was like okay
things were looking up and then he gets
his thing cut off by a helicopter oh man
Dawn of the Dead held the record for
coolest helicopter related zombie murder
for years until 2007 28 weeks later set
the new gold standard by sending Michael
from lost into a rotor powered zombie
killing spree and zombie kill number
four
okay I know what you're saying but wait
28 weeks later isn't a zombie movie
neither is 28 days later all right
doesn't listen it's about an army of
unstoppable infected who can turn you
into one of them if they bite you that
so yeah you take that rage virus and you
take the fast zombies BS and you shove
it right up where the Sun don't shine
you two World War Z your zombies that's
what in World War Z Z stands for zombies
English speakers aren't the only ones
who can make kick-ass zombie movies one
of the silliest bloodiest ones in recent
years 2009 s dead snow straight at a
Norway
if you don't know dead snow I got two
words for you Nazi zombies yeah that's
right the Fuehrer's best and brightest
are not so alive and well in our number
three kill where these frozen Krauts
come up against one of man's greatest
weapons the snowmobile
[Music]
I apologize coming in at number two is
director Peter Jackson's low-budget
splatter fest brain dead also known as
Dead Alive before you was hanging out
with hobbits he was blasting brains all
over the set in this 1992 horror comedy
when this house full of zombies meets
the business end of a lawnmower Patty's
OVA
[Music]
[Applause]
like how cool would it have been if like
Gandalf had a giant lawnmower and like
he faced off with a field of orcs and
he's like your ass is grass their dogs
alone more we wrestled long and hard
over what our number one zombie kill of
all time would be but when it came right
down to it we had to choose one so
ridiculous so outlandish that even the
sci-fi channel hasn't thought of it
zombie versus shark
[Music]
now before you ask a where's the zombie
kill it's an obvious to me that the
zombie got a few good bites in which
means somewhere in the depths of the
ocean mankind's greatest killer lies and
wait
it's Samba shark copyright howl Rudnick
2015 Asylum call me that's a lot of dead
zombies hey what's your favorite that we
left off the list let us know in the
comments section below best answer
you're gonna send your screen junkies a
t-shirt I want to thank you for watching
and if you liked the video go ahead and
share it i'm how run Nick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye
thanks to Scouts guide to the zombie
apocalypse for sponsoring today's show
to watch the official trailer click the
link in the description below and tell
them scream junkie sent ya
[Music]